- He's funny, he's talented,
he has many, many cars
even though none of us
have anywhere to go, right?
Okay, he's the host of Jay Leno's Garage
which you can watch Wednesdays on CNBC.
I am talking about the
one and only, Jay Leno.
Are you there Jay?
- I'm right here.
How're you doing, Kelly?
- I'm good, you look sharp.
How do you still look this sharp?
Look at me, I look like I'm
going to a volleyball game
and you look like you're about to host
the show again like you (laughing)
- No, no, no, that's what happens
when you have a little tiny
postage stamp iPhone thing.
Everybody looks good but actually I--
(laughing loudly)
- All right, well, we
were actually just talking
about quarantine gardening.
Do you garden?
- Right.
Do I garden?
You know, I tried.
Between the mulch, the
fertilizer, the garden tools,
I realized it's costing
about 1500 bucks a tomato
and I realized okay, well this is
(laughing loudly)
because, you know.
There's really no vegetable shortage.
I mean, there's plenty of produce.
There's no reason people to
have panic like that, you know.
So
- Yeah
- For now I have to say no.
The garden thing did not
work out in my favor.
- No, I think the thing
that Reed was talking
to us earlier about, was
that he just had some
older family members as
well he didn't really want
going to the grocery stores.
He was like trying, he asked a farmer
and his name is Jacob, the farmer
and he gave his produce
away for free just to like
pay it forward and it
was really really sweet.
And anyway, I have only gardened once.
I actually nailed it but it
just is so time consuming.
I don't have a lot of time but--
- Yeah, plus I'm more of a carnivore.
So, if anybody's got an extra
cow they don't want, you know.
- Yeah.
- Okay, I'll take that.
- Well, I'm on a ranch,
so we've got plenty of those, brother.
So (laughing loudly)
- Yeah, you know okay.
Well then we can work something out.
- We're not going hungry here (laughing)
All right well, how is quarantine going?
Because I know that you know,
you and I are both people
that are used to being on the road.
So how's it been like being stuck at home?
Or really, how hard is it for your wife
having you around that much?
(laughing)
- No, you know something but, I mean
I live sort of a quarantined life.
I come home every night
when I'm on the road,
almost no matter where I am.
Unless I'm past the Mississippi
River, anything west
of Mississippi, I'd just
come home every night.
So, it's really not a huge change for me.
Plus I'm not a I never explained,
I'm a never explain, never
complained kinda guy.
You know I don't, like
you said, you and I both
very fortunate to be in
this business and we both
doing okay, so we don't have
to be out there hustling.
So yeah, I can't say it's been terrible.
It's okay.
- Yeah, no, that's, I always try
and keep perspective
you know, at all times.
But are you optimistic about how all
this is gonna play out, or what are you--
- Yes, I am.
You know why?
Because I saw this Dr.Fauci
guy on TV and he said,
- Yeah.
- "This is a war,
and we have to fight it like a war."
And then a reporter says,
"Well how do we do that?"
And he says, "By staying home
and watching television."
I thought well, if there's any war
Americans uniquely qualified,
(laughing loudly)
to fight, it's this one.
I mean, I have been training
for this my whole life.
I sit home and watch TV, how hard it that?
And then I saw like, some dopey celebrity,
I won't say who it is.
I saw him on the show and he said that,
"You know, I feel like a
prisoner of war in my own home."
I went, okay.
But you know, this is the
first conflict in history
where the prisoners of war
are fatter at the end, okay
(laughing)
Okay, because nobody,
nobody starved to death here.
- Yeah, well and it's funny
'cause I have seen thing,
I won't mention anything
either because I know
people are just trying to distract people
and it's, you know what,
they're just trying
to do their own thing.
But it's funny 'cause I'm like,
no one wants to see a celebrity
in their really nice house,
like being like, "I'm so trapped."
(laughing) It's like a really nice house.
- Right, exactly.
Yeah, just shut up, just shut up.
I have always--
- Do yourself a favor.
- That's right, I am a huge
believer in low self esteem.
(laughing)
I'm on of the...
I believe that if you don't
think you're the smartest person
in the room, you'll shut
up and you'll listen.
And that's what I try to do.
I don't wanna give advice.
I mean, I used to love those things.
And I think NBC, still does them.
"We wanted you to know,"
and they would have
some set up and they'll go,
"Food, give it to your
kids they'll like it.
"We wanted you to know."
You know, I thank you.
Thank you very much idiot.
- Yeah.
- That's enough.
- How hard is it though?
'Cause I know as a comedian, you must be,
how are you trying out your jokes?
Are you trying them out on Mavis?
You can't hit the club
- This is it.
I'm here, I'm talking to you babes.
(laughing)
I thought I slipped a couple in there.
I saw you laugh so I said,
"Okay, I guess they're working."
- See, they are working.
You're testing that on me.
- Well, you know it is.
Because it is, you see a how
a lot of celebrities are...
Like I just read today, Jesse Smollett,
he actually paid two guys
to beat him up via FaceTime.
because--
(laughing)
- Oh my God, that is so wrong.
- No but see, now you can't go,
"It's wrong" and then laugh.
Because no, you can't.
- No, 'cause it can be wrong
but still be very funny.
- I would see a woman laugh at a joke
and shake her head, no.
I go, what, wait, you can't laugh
and shake your head, no.
- You can.
- It's either,
you're offended and you
hate it, or you laugh.
But you can't go, "Oh, that's terrible."
And then laugh at the joke.
- I think you can be equally
offended and also laugh
like, I've laughed at me and people,
when people, especially if
they're making fun of me.
Man, if it's a good one,
I'll laugh with you.
If it's like funny,
I'm like, there for it.
Like I can shake my head and laugh.
- I saw on the news that
a tiger at the Bronx Zoo,
has this Coronavirus.
- Really?
- And that shows
how ahead of the curve I've always been.
'Cause I always try to
keep six feet between me
and a tiger 'cause I don't
want to catch anything.
(laughing)
So if I see a tiger, I try
to have that barrier, so--
- Before and I would have walked up
and just hugged it, yeah.
- That's right, exactly.
- Luckily, people are giving
us this distance message.
Thank you for saving our lives.
- But there are tips, like
they said, the Coronavirus
can live on plastic for up to three days.
So if you're in Beverly
Hills, don't touch the women.
(laughing loudly)
- Don't touch anyone's boobs.
- That's right.
- All right.
Well, have you have and Mavis...
Are you all like, stocked up?
Did you go to the store and just stock up?
- Well we go to this,
you know what's so funny, I
went to the Ralph's Market
right down the street here,
right near our, where we
both used to do our show.
And they have a thing
where if you're over 60,
you go to the front of the line.
So I'm standing in line, you know,
I'm at the end of the line.
And the security guy goes,
"Hey, Mr.Leno you're over 60 right?"
I go, "Yell, I'm well over, I'm 70."
He goes, "Well, you can go
to the front of the line."
"Oh okay, great!"
So as I'm walking here, people go,
"Jay Leno's a celebrity (mumbles)"
So now I start limping, like ah!
Now I'm limping as I'm walking
you know, to get some sympathy.
- Yeah.
- And so a lady goes,
"Oh, go ahead Leno,
"you look like you're
a little bit of pain.
"I feel like that everyday."
(laughing)
I feel like that, remember
the guy in the Titanic
to put on the dress suit and
get in a lifeboat, you know.
So I sneak into Ralph's like this, ah!
You know, to get myself so, yeah.
But no, yeah we're pretty stocked up.
- All right, well, are you
enjoying quality time with Mavis?
Because, I know that there are times
that I want to strangle my husband, so--
- No actually we get along good.
You know, we're marriage for...
You know, the funny thing
- Oh, you bragger
(laughing)
- About being married for 40 years,
you get a rhythm thing going.
- Yeah.
- Like I don't understand
these like, I don't know
what I would do with a 25er.
Like my wife and I,
when this thing started,
"Oh, let's watch a movie."
So we sit down watch something on Netflix.
I fall asleep about halfway through.
She falls asleep a little bit later.
The movie ends I go,
"Honey, what happens?"
She goes, "I don't know."
I go, "Good, we've got something
to watch tomorrow, great!"
(laughing)
We go,
you know, I never understood
why my parents watched
the same "Matlock" over and over again.
- Oh my God, I love "Matlock"
- But now I do.
Yeah but now I do, now I get
it, now I understand why.
Oh, I see, they fall asleep before the end
then they have to watch the
whole thing all over again.
So it's actually okay.
- That's my husband's law.
- No, I enjoy my time
with my wife.
We have we have a lot of
fun, we get along good.
And so that makes it really good.
- Oh, me my husband, well,
we're a younger couple than y'all.
So we are, we've definitely
wanted to kill each other at some point.
But we will aim for your
status, like your love--
- Yeah, there you go.
- We're aiming for your love.
All right ,well, have you been
getting out on drives still?
Like, are you using your
all those cars you own?
- Well you know, I'm here
in my garage right now.
This thing behind me is
called the 3D printer.
We use it to make parts
when I work on cars.
- Are you serious?
- But what we've been doing,
yeah, we've been making these.
We've been making these masks
and we make them for free.
And the machine runs 24 hours a day,
we got a couple of them here
and we turn out these masks.
We just make this part, this plastic part,
another guy makes this part.
- Yeah.
- And you sort of put them on like this.
You know, like, you would a mask.
And we give them free.
We just make them for free,
we just turn them out all day.
We give them to the fire department
and they give the first responders.
So you feel like you're doing something.
- Yeah.
- You know,
I always tell people,
maybe you got old blankets,
maybe got things you can
give to the Goodwill.
I mean, everybody could do something
to help out a little bit.
And that's kind of what we're doing.
I mean, I enjoy working on
my cars but this machine
doesn't make parts all the time.
So, what we do is we just, for
the last two or three weeks,
we've had it running.
This is all the spare pieces here.
And we, this is what they look like
when they come out of the printer.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, and we just bang these
out and it's really cool.
And we give them the first responders
and who else, whoever wants them.
- That's really cool.
And I know you said it makes you feel good
and feel like you're
helping but you are helping.
That's a really incredibly cool thing.
You could be, like you said,
you could just be like a lot
of Americans are sitting at
home watching TV and eating.